welcome back everybody it's time to
salute our everyday heroes with
southwest medical let's introduce you
to this week's honorees congratulations
alejandro and dion salute to you
both thank you thanks a lot how do you
feel i know they surprised
you uh absolutely uh it
came out of nowhere i actually thought
it was a mistake
i thought it was a mistake i said they
they're not talking about me but then
when i read it
and then reread it and then reread it
again i said okay maybe
maybe it really is really really was a
shock and
um very humbling and very much an honor
beautiful and alejandra how are you well
of
feeling
i'm elated and happy uh happy with the
company also
but actually same with her i just found
out yesterday
uh actually my emails are the one
produce
and told me to see the emails and then i
said
it's a scam or what it's so funny
because you guys
you're so modest but really what will we
do without you
you're so important to the community and
so let's introduce
yourselves because you're always taking
care of everybody else let's talk about
you for a change
what do you do what's your specialty i'm
a
an adult medicine physician assistant
and i've been here with the company
for three years now so um
myself along with my team of physicians
and nurse practitioners that i work with
are responsible for
overseeing and coordinating primary care
for our adult population ages 18 and up
wow alejandro how about you what's your
specialty i'm
i've been here in the company for one
year and three months
prior to that i'm specializing in urgent
care and critical care
my primary job is to see patients
and do quick assessments
and save lives what actually
makes a good day for you on the day to
day
because i know you see some you see a
lot and it's not easy
a good day for me um is really when
i am able to get a plan in place i mean
part of medicine
is knowing that we may not have all the
answers up front
but it does bring me a lot of comfort in
knowing okay
everyone has a plan of action and a plan
of care
and that not only am i comfortable with
that but
they leave the office comfortable with
the next steps and
and that sort of thing so alejandra how
about you
my mom is a good day is for me is uh
going to the clinic seeing my team
smiling telling each other we can do
this today
okay and overall seeing patients and
then
you know deep down telling myself okay i
did something good
uh they're satisfied they're happy and
when they go home
they will tell their parents or they
will tell the relatives okay you
probably need to go to
that clinic they're superb so that's a
good day for me
all these segments always make me smile
congrats to our superheroes of the week
thank you both for all you do every
single day we'll be right back